chris trenton congratulations you've
both made it to the final round and are
one step closer to ten thousand dollars
so far you've come to our forge and
you've made a weapon of your choosing
now you're gonna head back to your home
forge
and you're gonna create a weapon of our
choosing
[Music]
and that mystery weapon is
[Music]
the chakra
the shock room is an indian throwing
weapon which dates back hundreds of
years
warrior sikhs would throw it like a
frisbee or spin it at high speeds on
their fingers before launching it into
the enemy
weapon of the hindu god vishnu its
exotic nature has resulted in it
appearing in tv and movies
odd job's lethal bowler hat in the james
bond movie goldfinger was a variation of
the weapon as was xena's weapon of
choice in the cult tv series the indian
warriors would wear multiple shock rooms
into battle carrying them around their
arms their necks and even stacked high
on their heads in specially designed
turbines
we will see you in five days
my name is trenton thai i am not trent
who is a blacksmith i am trent the
blacksmith what i had to do is go to the
junkyard and find a very particular
piece for a jig a particular item to
allow you to very carefully control the
contours of the item you're working on
and laying under some oak trees i find
an old oxygen tank
and so what we have now
is our chakram form
next i actually welded a stock just some
place to give me some leverage i'm going
to heat the bar and start bending it
around my jig so now i need to weld
these pieces together
[Music]
and there we go we have a hoop formed
this is going to be my base material for
my braided handle normally use it for
knife handles but i'm going to be using
this for the middle of our
chakram and there she is
the last thing that i'm going to do is
focus on making her pretty
this is going to be so kick-ass
[Music]
my name is christopher farrell being a
professional bladesmith you don't make a
lot of money winning this competition
will make the next year of operation
costs a lot easier to shoulder
i don't have anything in my shop to
accommodate this shape
most people probably have a jig set up
so that they could pull this around a
lot easier i don't have a jig so i've
been doing a combination of rounding it
on the horn of the anvil and using the
bevel to help round it further
pretty close i'm done with the initial
shaping
the only issues that i think i may run
into is forge welding the seam
of the shock room because it might get
burned
the heat is very inconsistent it's very
difficult to control precisely where
you're heating up in a charcoal forge
you're kidding me right
we burned that too hot somewhere else
not hot enough where the well needs to
happen so i'm going to cut out the
sections of the chakra that were ruined
and weld on a new section and being a
guy who works mostly with hand tools i
want to see if i can pull it off
it'll work out
or it won't
well it ain't perfect but
for the strength tests we're going to
take your chakrams and see if it was
designed well as a throwing weapon we're
going to use a specially designed
mechanical device that will launch your
weapon into the sugar canes because
sugar canes have similar consistency as
human limbs
if your weapon can cut cleanly through a
sugar cane that would indicate that you
have a weapon that would do mass
destruction in the field of battle
this device here is calibrated so that
every throw is going to be the same for
each of your designs chris you're first
are you ready yes sir
in three two one engage
that's cool
well chris
it cut two sugar canes
i see no indentations on the edges here
this will cause maximum damage in the
battlefield
good job fantastic thank you
okay trenton
you're up next
in three two one engage
i watch mine just kind of do an
overarching arc just a bloop
it hits the sugar cane very low just a
couple of inches off the ground however
it shears them and that means i'm good
well trenton because of the weight
obviously it didn't
fly out as high but it did cut
this definitely will be an ankle cutter
trenton's piece it's still cut-ish
now for the kill test
the chakram is primarily a throwing
weapon
however in close quarter combat
sometimes throwing a weapon is not an
option
trenton you're up first
this is designed to be a handle correct
yes sir so in order to keep myself safe
i'm going to hold the handle
and i have to protect the back of my arm
with this so on the design alone that's
a concern let's find out what it does
uh
well trenton that performed quite well
it cut some ribs and it disemboweled the
dummy
it will kill
good job trenton chris you're up next
excellent
[Music]
wow well it really opened him up
in the belly here so he's totally
disemboweled
definitely cut through all the way and
broke a rib
it'll kill
you have both performed outstandingly
however
there can only be one winner of ten
thousand dollars
[Music]
chris
you are the forged empire champion
congratulations
trenton
unfortunately your weapon did not make
the cut
shockram has to be a light fast weapon
so i have some problems with the weight
of that weapon and once you added that
handle in the middle you left the realm
of chakram and went into the realm of
fantasy
and it kills me because i love looking
at it but when it came down to a chakram
that would work in combat it had to go
to chris
trenton
please surrender your weapon
of course i'm disappointed
fought real hard
thanks
i'm sorry
man chris he did an awesome job that's
the kind of person you want to lose to
chris congratulations you will receive a
check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations chris and function and
form and historical accuracy your blade
performed the best i'm a little in shock
chris isn't here anymore please leave a
message
[Music]
you